foreign  [Music]  [Music]  any attack if there's an attack on  parliament it is an attack on the  democrats of the people of south africa  which we so  hardly fought for  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  much as it is disappointing  devastating  there is something  that we can be grateful for for these  men and women  in  uniform who  go into the most dangerous places that  you can ever think of risking their limb  and their lives  now this building is very important to  south africans it is a place that is the  heartbeat of democracy it's where the  parliamentarians gather to debate  policy and legislation it's also where  the president delivers his state of the  nation address and it's where nelson  mandela was elected as the first black  president of south africa now there will  be some significant costs involved in  refurbishing this building and  there's obviously a lot of history  behind these buildings walls  you